cela fait 26 ans qu'existe le concours
d'élégance auto moto rétro sur montigny
le bretonneux et cette année on aurait
envie de crier vive la mariée à chaque
édition un nouveau thème imposé pour
tous les passionnés de voitures de
collection venus présenter leurs modèles
nous avons remporté le premier prix du
concours d'élégance
c'est vrai que le thème cérémonie et
mariage se prêter à ce que on les gens
ont eu envie de décorer et ça j'ai
trouvé que c'était exceptionnel quand
même très inspiré patricia su mettre en
valeur sa coccinelle volkswagen
cabriolet karman de 1971
c'est le modèle 13 cents de s
un moteur 16 cents un carburateur weber
double corps c'est une neuf chevaux
la coccinelle de patricia partager le
podium avec une jaguar une bentley une
fiat 500 une simca et trois motos
l'événement organisé par le club les
montants des vieux pistons s'est déroulé
pour la première fois au château de la
couldre sous un grand soleil très très
belle journée y ait beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de voitures diversifié de
toutes marques confondues toutes marques
confondues il y avait à peu près pas
loin de 200 voitures
le public lui aussi est venu nombreux
grands parents parents ou enfants
il n'y a pas d'âge pour aimer les
moteurs
ça fait peur c'est impressionnant aïe il
ça permet en plus de réunir un petit peu
tous les gens et c'est très convivial
très agréable était super de voir toutes
ces voitures en plus 6 et il était belle
moi j'aime bien aimé est la voiture la
barre elle était belle avec les pompes
et merci le club des vieux pistons donne
rendez vous à tous les amateurs de
véhicules anciens dimanche 23 septembre
sur la commune de mesnil saint denis
pour la rencontre au modélisme et de
l'automobile